the faces of Alexander Petrov and Ruslan
basarov have now been seen around the
world but their whereabouts and their
real names remain unknown
around 250 detectives have crawled
through more than 11,000 hours of CCTV
the two individuals named by the police
and CPS are officers from the Russian
military intelligence service the
British government has shown its hand
evidence which includes the men's
arrival at Gatwick Airport on Russian
passports my new traces of Nava
chocolate in East London hotel where
they stayed even a reconnaissance
mission in Salisbury the day before the
attack according to the resume enough to
show that the poisoning of former
Russian spies circus [ __ ] and his
daughter Yulia was almost certainly
approved at a senior level by the
Russian state but over in Russia Elyas
cousin has her own theories
Theresa May said once that it's Russia
that won't change tack now especially
not before elections in Parliament she
needs to win votes also it's been half a
year since it happened so they need to
show results this is the result on
Russian TV as the men's mug shots were
shown to the nation the news was met
with claims of rampant Russia phobia
while officials accused British
authorities of being unwilling to engage
a cheetah that icsq garden a factor of
usually a Russian citizen that enters
Britain from Russia in order to receive
a British visa they have to leave copies
of their fingerprints with the embassy
we have requested copies of those
fingerprints which naturally the British
government have refused to give us just
like all the other material we
previously requested was a Brazilian
[ __ ] at key points of the cps hasn't
asked to extradite the men knowing that
when it comes to its own citizens Russia
won't with enough evidence to charge the
pair over what went on in Salisbury the
European arrest warrant has been issued
but it is unlikely they'll ever face
justice in the UK so what next could we
see more tip for tat expulsion of
diplomats travel bans or Russian assets
frozen
the fact is Russia will only really feel
the difference if to resume can persuade
her European counterparts to support her
on sanctions we're going to get a lot
actually you but I think we will be able
to keep a modest increase of pressure
economically in other ways on Russia so
it's more important to keep United than
make gestures which will have no effect
we on ourselves can't win this we have
to be keen coming bringing together a
substantial body of countries 4050 of
countries who are ready to take United
action and that's possible the partner
of dawn Sturgis who died after being
exposed to the same nerve agent says he
hopes that people are brought to justice
for her death in a statement Charlie
Rowley said it's upsetting to see Dawn's
face everywhere because it brings all
the hurt and pain at losing her back to
reality but he added it is progress to
see the suspects identified in the
script our case however with Russia
continuing to deny any involvement it's
difficult to see what further progress
can be expected Katie Spencer Sky News